josh is with us to start off this hour
he's in chicago
hey josh how are you hey dave it's a
pleasure speaking with you guys hey
anthony
uh how are you guys doing great man how
can we help
um hi so i'm uh started listening to the
show maybe about two months ago so still
relatively new to the process
working through the baby steps i'm on
one step one right now
um more or less my career
i have a job work that pays relatively
well but i'm just not really happy i did
feel like god called me to do
what i'm doing at the time when i got
the job but it's kind of been a very
difficult process
i'm trying to figure out how to work in
possibly looking for an
alternate job into the baby step program
i guess is my question in a nutshell
you mean change jobs while you're
working baby steps
right okay what do you make now
right now i'm i make about 50 a year
yeah fit five zero
yeah fifty thousand yeah and you're how
old i'm 27.
what do you do i'm a biomedical
technician so i
i repair dialysis equipment okay
and what would you change too
that kind of becomes a little bit of a
the thing like so i'm a very social
person and i
i very much so enjoy speaking with
people and
the kind of work that i do now is very
socially isolating so it uh
i guess the the easiest answer is it
doesn't bring joy to my heart to do what
i'm doing now even though i know i'm
helping people so i want to find
something that i'm able to
invest into others
yeah that's pretty broad yeah i don't
know where you put that resume in
right right now you you got to be
intentional
and and it doesn't sound like you're
being intentional so
uh no i don't think it's a good
opportunity it's a good time for you to
change
careers now let's just say this all
right you need to go through ken
coleman's process
right yeah and once you do that and you
identify i want to work
doing i want to be one of those whatever
that is
or something that has these components
to it
whatever that's a little more than just
i don't want to work with machines i
want to work with people i get that
that's a
but but that does that leaves the entire
world open that you could do there's a
lot of stuff you can do out there that
that with that as your guidelines so
you're gonna have to get more clarity
on where you're going number one and you
can do that while you're working to get
out of debt
and um once you know what that is then
we gotta figure out what that pays now
here's the deal
if it pays fifty thousand dollars a year
or more
and you can land the job it doesn't harm
your debt snowball at all as a matter of
fact it helps it for you to make the
move
if it pays 30 000 a year and you make 50
now now we got to stop and think about
it maybe not
[Music]
but if it's a lateral or up move why
wouldn't you
yeah a lot of the jobs that i've been
looking at would be uh
not not as high of an income you know
why because you don't have it clarified
you haven't set a goal you just kind of
generally went i want out of here and
who's hiring well who's hiring his entry
level always
so we need to have a little bit better
clarity on your career path and this
might take six months
for you to land a better job but but
you're not gonna die there in six months
i mean you're just you just need to see
some human beings is all you're saying
and you'll get there you're gonna be
fine what we don't want to sign up for
is ten years of doing this and doing
nothing about it
right right but ten month ten months you
can survive while you find the right
clarity
uh but no i don't want you moving down i
want a matter of fact even if you were
out of debt and you just called and went
i think i want to be happy good move up
that makes you happier
if they if you found something paid a
hundred thousand with people involved
you'd be a lot happier
very much so yeah so let's do that i
mean why do we have to make the
assumption that in order to be happy we
have to make less money
it generally works the other way around
by the way but you know what dave this
younger generation
really they will prefer happiness over
making good but they're not independent
they're not on the same spectrum unhappy
or happy does not mean broke
it's not it doesn't mean you have to
make less to be happy that is true
you don't you don't have to do that you
can just find a different way to do the
thing that makes you happy
that the society will pay you for yeah
i'm not saying money makes you happy but
a hundred thousand is a lot easier to
work with than 30.
absolutely i agree with you trust me i'm
talking about this on my show
i know i'm saying i know it's just but
it can run coleman runs into this all
the time i'm gonna
i want to have work that has meaning and
great so get some work that has meaning
help a whole bunch of people and get
paid a lot
exactly you know i got i have work that
has meaning i'm doing pretty good
sure you know me too we're helping a lot
of people so it's
you know you don't have to be broke to
be happy
or work for a non-profit which by the
way is not a biblical construct
that is an irs guideline every
non-profit is
profitable or they close
they go broke it's an accounting entry
it's not a holiness factor there's no
such thing
you can't you know i'll guarantee you
man
the the uh the doctor that you go see is
in it
and and it brings healing to your life
is as much a ministry as your preacher
oh so good i mean it's just
that that's work is worship when done
with the right motives and when you're
serving and helping people
so uh this this idea that you have to
work for some
entity to be holy no it's the work you
do
and how you do it in the spirit you do
it with and by the way if you help a
whole bunch of people
as our friend says they will give you
certificates of appreciation with
president's faces on them i love that
rabbi daniel lapin in the book thou
shall prosper one of our buddies says
that all the time
yeah so it's a great question it's a
great question so what we want to do
in your case josh is attack the
construct
that you're dealing with which made you
call and say
i think i need to make less to be happy
and should i do that on the debt
snowball
no you shouldn't you should go make more
and be happy
and then you don't even have to ask the
question yeah i agree
go to kencoleman.com download uh some of
his materials there's lots of stuff
there free
it'll get you going he's got the seven
stack steps the first one is to get
clear
yeah the seven stages of working and
finding the dream job the first ones get
clear clarity
and you don't have that yet josh yeah
all you know is you don't like where you
are you don't know what you like
and i recommend josh take some time call
into his show tomorrow yeah he'll help
you walk through the process real
quickly on his show so go to
kencomashow.com
uh look at the hours there within your
city give give us a call
he'll probably be more gentle than i was
yeah a lot more that's why i didn't say
too much but
kim would take kim will take real good
care of you uh bro
call him tomorrow he'll even give you a
copy of the book just tell him dave and
anthony said
you'll give us a copy oh we can give him
a copy yes
all right why don't you think so don't
you think so thank you being for nice
dave well you're you're the nice guy you
brought it up
yeah lee proximity principle number one
best seller by ken coleman on helping
you get a job and the thing you love
kelly's gonna give josh one yes since i
was mean to him thank you
this is the ramsey show